jo leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde ender games mit krankhafter der
steht er neben mir und mit tags so bist
du eben mit dem rücken zum manager
hallo da hinter dem haus an logos hd der
grinch einige zurück zu einem baukasten
schauen wir mal wer gut wollen wir auch
noch ein kurzes briefing geben was das
spiele spielen gibt's nämlich seine
erste runde
ja ja klar so vielleicht ja hinter hat
sie verdienen ja wohl reif für den do
würstchen
mai kam auch das würstchen fertig
daran erinnert ganz geschafft haben und
gerade eben schon versucht gehabt ein
weniger erfolgreichen aufzunehmen wo er
jetzt sind wir alle zusammen eine lobby
und warum das video etwas später kommt
kann erklären was dazwischen gekommen
ist ja also ich habe er versucht mit
raul aufzunehmen beruhigt dich doch
einfach mal ein bisschen und zwar
dreimal weg war just junge nicht so
schreiben die mir steht die kleine
schwester ist mein bruder schreibt ja
ich habe mehr als mit raul auf zudem ein
computer der hölle gelegt jetzt keine
ahnung was er jetzt macht jetzt geht es
gerade wir machen natürlich dass er lag
bei 15 sekunden hat man immer stand
beträgt plugin also ich hab gerade stand
ich weiß nicht welche stand wird es tot
vielleicht doch nur ein paar leute keine
ahnung
auf jeden fall steht bei mir minecraft
104 keine rückstände aber dass niemand
in der nähe hinter mir einer gekämmt sei
die schutzzeit lief alter so ein
hundezone ich war darf was echt bist du
hinter mir ich war nicht zu unserer
jungen
also ich hab ich habe schon als aber im
wichtigsten sind helm und rüstung weil
es gibt manche spieler die verfolgen so
die taktik das design
sie stecken sich hoch damit dann andere
leute runter fallen wenn man getauscht
wird
aber da gibt es einen trick wenn man
nämlich im schuhe anhat und snk kriegt
man maximal fünf herzen falsch halten
also man kann nicht sterben ja das ist
der sport tipp von krankhafter das heißt
das heißt man kann auch im falle nobs
nicht aktivieren
jetzt nicht ok ok danke finde ich mir
dabei zeigt auch mit lustig kennt man
den schon mal gehört was ich hab halbes
leben was da vor krebs nur passend dass
lieber auf das cebs da fracht- und
hacker in der runde schreibt man ja der
hacker habe ich wahrscheinlich bald
gekillt lubbadeh lebst du nur nein
projektpate man ja ok bestätigt also
leute meinen rechner lag gerade der
hölle ich habe keiner master abgeht ich
mal formalitäten jetzt gekündigt
ja ich hab dings logisch zerstört gut in
der luft zerfetzt schreib mal irgendwas
nettesten entfällt dieser speedcuber
heckt vielleicht des dessauer von gome
ist so ein bisschen also dass die
plugins angeht ist der echt mega geil
aber es gibt ein paar sachen hacker und
so performance also text und sowas wurde
er noch ein bisschen verbessert werden
könnte finde ich aber dass gleich kein
geheimnis
auf jeden fall die plugins in der liga
geht wo man die union nicht mehr machen
kann
nein es gibt leichten unsichtbarkeit
rang aber vielleicht helfen
ich glaube das ist ja echt unsichtbaren
jedenfalls keine löcher der ganze
angegriffen sportarten hast du schwarzen
herzen dann bist du vielleicht zu nah an
der kuppel sag ich mal
natürlich seien
da musst du einfach ein bisschen weiter
karten innere lassen
in der kuppel gibt's das bitte zunächst
gibt diese imaginäre kontexte sonst auch
tut jetzt musste ich unsere jährige
vertrete unsere er krank war oder vorne
wird gefightet ich mich mal ein mit
bogen skills das kind das ich habe hat
die eigenschaft wenn man ein mob tötet
dann kriegt man drei herzen und das ist
schon so ein schild also wenn man im
kampf ist habe ich die erfahrung gemacht
dann gehe ich manchmal einfach hin und
und schießt irgendwie ein huhn ab oder
so und teure geräte durch etwas so ein
ding ja drei herzen direkt gerätetyp
betet für motta herzen für einen player
für die ganze leiste das ist ja richtig
krass die bremer sind so hart oder der
firma auch gut
ja ich weiß aber er wagt bei mir
zumindest in der punkt wir noch mal
schauen also bei wir setzen in so einer
unterwasser höhle und schaut war das
laufen hat bei den links bernd ihm
vorbei und hole mir von herzen dass das
so zähle ich halte aber man es einfach
machen kann man jetzt mal hinterher hier
so ich kämpfe gegen google places nach
den kenne ich aber das ist ein kamerad
turnier eigentlich ja leute in den
videos die ich mit raul schon versucht
habe aufzunehmen die leider
fehlgeschlagen sind
ging es darum was wir 2014 uns vornehmen
ich würde uns das thema könnten wir
jetzt vielleicht noch mal kurz alle
stimmen
auch wenn es jetzt schon drei vier fünf
mal erzählt haben wegen den völligen
fehlgeschlagenen aufnahmen einfach mal
an und zwar ich nehme für 2014 vor
möglichst jeden tag ein video zu
produzieren ist es tatsächlich so bei
mir wenn ich mal irgendwie einen tag
lang ein video machen dann dann fühle
ich mich irgendwie schlecht
ich habe einfach lust jeden tag video zu
machen
und ja ich hoffe dass sie auch lust
drauf habt euch die videos anzuschauen
und in diesem sinne werde ich jetzt
versuchen jeden tag wieder zu machen
darüber hinaus möchte ich in der uni
noch bisschen mehr gas geben also mein
ziel ist schon ein einschnitt das sollte
schon drin sein und schlussendlich noch
drei mal die woche ins fitnessstudio
gehen das sind meine ziele natürlich
kämpfe ich kämpfe und ich würde sagen
jetzt übergebe ich mal das mikro an den
text so na ja also ich hab mir auch ganz
ganz viele sachen vorgenommen für 2014
einerseits youtube angeht ja so ein
bisschen bessere qualität aus knüppeln
und so bist du auf eure weniger hässlich
sein
ich werde noch hübsch noch übrig als
jetzt schon
ich bin gerade voll taktisch am zweiten
weil die andere leute sie mir überlegen
also rüstungsmesse und so aber irgendwie
haben sie doch ab es ist nicht so
christus über links und ist behindert
ich hab noch zwei risse ins passt ja
aber jetzt kein bus panzer ergänzt jetzt
noch mal den service meine schule gas
geben dann ja sport mehr treiben auch so
fitnessstudio meter max da weil wir noch
mal wissen reden müssen
wisst ihr ich bin doch schon klasse
story geht weiter schreibt mal granit
ist klotz in die kommentare
mit meinen kommentaren so ich muss jetzt
ich habe glück gehabt ich bin hier acht
direkt tätig eine rüstung hier vor mir
fliegen immer hinterher natürlich schon
mal ich habe um sich herum ist keiner
wie gott und hier zwischen dabei seid
granie ist klotz in die kommentare zu
schreiben schreib doch mal rein
was ihr euch für 2014 vorgenommen habt
lasst uns das wissen ja genau das war
supergut von euch ja genau
die karten dort seien ja die treten
richtig lächerlich
die was diese karten das sind wir sollen
doch zu viele gemerkt sein diesen
schalter okay würde bessere metzmachers
sollen doch einfach so normal wie jungen
sein der das ja warum und ihren also
mich nie die werden nicht zuviel
generiert er kenne die liga lebt auch
noch links besiegen shadow kräfte
hd-zeitalter shadow crafter die hat eine
komplette die aristo white lies namen
findet abgeordneten fahrer ist nicht
gleich von links getöteten die
kommentare strecke branche verbesserte
ihren frieden haben wenn ihr mich mein
vater hat mich total halbes herz
stillsteht esel okay ich habe wieder
sein heil auf den kommentar sachen beste
leben
das ist so peinlich du musst aber drei
tiere töten lassen wir voller leben ich
habe es geschafft mehr verfolgt mich
nicht mit jetzt wie soll der letzte vor
der endkampf losgeht erzählt was du dir
vorgenommen was für 2014 oder was darf
ich schon habe ich schon mein video
gesagt ich möchte ein bisschen kontakt
in meinen kanal reinbringen
das heißt nicht die stadt am bodensee
sondern bettler andere sache und zwar
möchte ich projekte machen regelmäßig
auf einem kanal
und ansonsten so wie ihr bein also
fitness schön nichts vorgenommen welche
ja aber wenn man so genau habe ich mir
hast du ständig also für die schule zu
lernen zu was meinst du was ich hoffe es
ja mit mir den vorhaben bisher immer so
eine sache
er ist gerne viele dinge vor ein
autokrat viele der [ __ ] hat sich
darum hingestellt ist wie runterfallen
herzlich genau in eine schlucht gestellt
der miese sack und hat eine switching
da wurden wir einfach das match und
spielt das überlebt das ist das
wichtigste
ja ich komme jetzt zu den beiden zu
finden hatte zwei youtube erst als ein
sucht kind wenn wir das schaffen cello
crafter so kennt und die laser aus ich
habe schon öfter getroffen
die register aus jetzt nur noch max
gegen shadow crafter gps in den einkaufs
pack hätten hier
okay okay jetzt geht's richtig ab hier
vorreiter dieser nur zu
walter fulda werte sie bitte fuldaer
geholt die kck der hacker egal
showtalent ich würde mehr heißt keine
ahnung ich weiß es nicht mehr
war gut ja ich will sagen da hat uns
kurz damit dass wir jetzt schon hoch
kommt und damit auch damit mache damit
der aufgabe derart dass der hofft dass
der nicht nach unten gerutscht und weil
wir auch nicht nach unten gehen wollen
machen jetzt fertig verabschiedet euch
mal wieder sehen bis dann nicht 1000
leute die chance bis wieder der
mac-software von mir dass karl aloys
schnitzel